per dare il significato a qualsiasi
tecnologia è importante che quest'ultima
risponda dei bisogni e i bisogni si
modulano e variano in base a quella che
è la società
ed ecco che per un semplice sillogismo
comprendere quelle che sono le
tecnologie è fondamentale comprendere
quella che è la società
sì perché siamo dinanzi ad una nuova era
se ne sa che ha preceduto la scrittura è
stata definita come preistoria e quella
che si è posta nel mezzo delle più
grandi rivoluzioni ingegneristiche e
stata definita come storia oggi siamo
dinanzi all'era meglio definita come i
per storie una ruck ha la capacità per
tanto di includere quelle che sono le
cosiddette ai siti information and
communication technologies quindi tutte
quelle che sono le tecnologie che hanno
la capacità di elaborare di modulare e
di trasmettere informazioni
siamo totalmente immersi all'interno di
dati ecco perché possiamo definire oggi
la nostra epoca quella dell'info sfera
avere la capacità di comprendere i dati
sta a significare anche valutare come
questi ultimi si modificano all'interno
dell'ambiente tanto è vero che gli
ultimi studi vanno a definire una
crescita di tipo esponenziale di questi
dati ne andiamo ad individuare una
quantità di dati che non corrisponde più
a quelle che sono le denominazioni che
comuni
al giorno d'oggi quindi non mega non
giga non tera bensì zettabyte stiamo
parlando di una tale quantità di dati
che se volessimo confrontarla con un
click e in uno scatto di una fotocamera
riusciremo ad oggi a parlare di una
quantità di informazioni pareri gli ad
un milione di miliardi di foto scattate
in un singolo anno una quantità enorme
questo è un cambiamento assolutamente
epocale che va alle radici di quelle che
sono la società sta stravolgendo
assolutamente la società stessa
ma poi si che definiamo big data questi
grandi dati hanno tre caratteristiche
fondamentali la prima il volume lo
abbiamo definito precedentemente una
quantità che tende a definire in maniera
a crescere in maniera indefinita ed
esponenziale
seconda una varietà la quantità di
informazione oggi altamente variabile
uno smartphone che presente nelle vostre
tasche alla capacità ad oggi di
calcolare
quantità di il numero dei passi
calcolare sicuramente dove voi siete e
inneggiare queste informazioni ma ancora
uno smartwatch ad oggi la capacità di
determinare la il vostro battito
cardiaco con una precisione del 97 per
cento di accuratezza questo è una cosa
assolutamente incredibile
la variabilità ad oggi un domani sarà
sempre più levata le vostre lenti a
contatto avranno la capacità di
individuare la quantità di virginia
presente nel vostro sangue e la
temperatura del vostro corpo verrà ad
essere determinata dal vostro
abbigliamento e detto ed ecco che tutto
cambia ma cambia anche con una velocità
incredibile
basti pensare che gli ultimi studi
definiscono che nel 2025 il 30 per cento
dell'informazione sarà trasmessa realta
in pronta consegna
ed ecco che siamo dinanzi ad un processo
incredibile
un processo che vede queste information
communication technology che già dal
2010 hanno superato in media la
popolazione mondiale siamo già oltre
avremo nei prossimi anni un quantitativo
incredibile di dispositivi connessi che
dialogano tra loro per ogni singolo
soggetto presente sulla faccia della
terra
rischiamo a causa della nostra
evoluzione di tipo biologico e quindi di
un rallentamento dell'approccio nei
confronti di questa enorme quantità di
dati di rimanere fuori
perché la tecnologia attende ad
evolversi in maniera assolutamente
esponenziale ed ecco che i bisogni come
dicevamo all'inizio cambiano cambiano e
si modulano ad una velocità incredibile
ad oggi abbiamo il bisogno e la
necessità di interfacciarci nei
confronti di questi dati e nei confronti
di queste macchine in maniera definibile
come user friendly ovvero tutti i punti
che interconnettono il palmo della
nostra mano o qualche altra superficie
del nostro corpo ed interagiscono con la
macchina devo diventare sempre più
naturali qui cambia si evolve matura
questo è il significato profondo
filosofico e storico della mix di ale p
non parliamo della realtà aumentata
ovvero di dispositivi che hanno la
capacità di leggendoli marcatori di
elevare dei modelli tridimensionali
non stiamo parlando di realtà aumentata
in senso stretto dove leggiamo grazie a
piccoli primi ottici le informazioni
presenti e trasmesse davanti ai nostri
occhi non parliamo nemmeno del l'opposto
di realtà virtuale quindi di un mondo
totalmente artefatto che ci consegna
all'interno di una realtà completamente
diversa bensì parliamo di mixer royalty
unire il fisico al digitale in maniera
altamente fiorente dando significato a
quello che è il dato nel mondo stesso
uno dei più importanti ambienti in cui
questa rivoluzione storica avrà appunto
estremamente successo e rivoluzionerà
l'approccio con le macchine sarà proprio
quella della medicina perché oggi nella
medicina sia la capacità sia la
necessità e l'obbligo di dare senso
critico una mole di dati sempre più
elevata con una velocità sempre più
grande ecco perché ad oggi siamo dinanzi
ad un cambiamento che definiamo come
mixed reality ovvero davanti ai nostri
occhi un medico con l'usa continuando a
mantenere quella che l'usabilità delle
mani può percepire quella che la
cartella clinica di un paziente
avvicinarsi davanti ad una colonna
patologica cercando di individuare
quelle che sono le più fini
caratteristiche e condividendole per
quest'ultime in realtime colmo
oppure individuando dei grafici che
individuano quello che le prime
ideologie all'incidenza di queste
patologie
una serie interconnessa di sistemi
davanti ai nostri occhi coerenti a
quello che è lo spazio che ci circonda
siamo dinanzi ad una nuova era grazie
mille
[Applauso]
[Musica]